a gritos por el cambio
cientos de personas se tomaron las
calles de las principales ciudades de
américa latina y en apoyo al 25 en el 25
de noviembre día internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia en contra de
la mujer según onu mujeres en américa
latina se encuentran 14 de los 25 países
con los índices de feminicidios más
altos pero estos salimos a las calles
porque en méxico a pesar de que ha
llegado otro gobierno nos siguen
asesinando a las mujeres sin embargo la
violencia no es sólo física miles han
sido vulneradas en las redes sociales
son golpes reales cada like es como si
te pegarán como si te golpearan como si
te asesinaran como si intentaran una
navaja cada like a ese vídeo sexual es
como si si es como si te te
que violaran sin penetrar tu cuerpo
desde el año 1981 cada 25 de noviembre
se conmemora el asesinato de las
hermanas mirabal ocurrido en república
dominicana en 1960 en 2019 más de 4.600
mujeres fueron asesinadas en américa
latina' una cifra que podría superar el
2020 por la pandemia del cob y 19 donde
algunas mujeres se vieron obligadas a
convivir con sus agresores
más de 200 feminicidios fueron
reportados en américa latina' durante
los primeros meses de la crisis
sanitaria
estás exigiendo al gobierno que cumpla
un trabajo que sea garante de los
derechos que no se están cumpliendo
muchas mujeres viven
algunos analistas indican que el
problema se empezaría a resolver desde
casa educando tanto a niños y niñas
frente a la igualdad de ambos géneros
mientras tanto la lucha continua para
conseguir el reconocimiento de y el
respeto a la mujer en la región